[Music]  see the problem is I think that the  culture is a flight from reality all  culture is a flight from reality so to  the degree that you are normal  whether you're we toto or Manhattan  night or Parisian but to the degree that  you are normal  you are very successfully taking part in  the flight the cultural flight from  reality you are supporting the mass  hallucination and paying dues into it  and it's difficult in an age like now  where there's so much stress on  ethnicity and community and roots and  all that to preach this to preach that  culture is not your friend  it's a trap it's a limit but really a  radical human freedom is what you were  born for and culture is a kind of  placenta which if you develop normally  by around age 20 you have no need of it  and in fact you've recognized the toxic  nature of it and are trying to put it  behind you and and get away from  [Music]  you